[Musica]
sa di polvere da sparo si diceva nella
prima 1972
l'astronauta dell'apollo 16 charlie duke
era appena rientrato da una passeggiata
sulla luna un po di polvere lunare gli
era rimasta attaccata alla tuta spaziale
e questa polvere invaso l'abitacolo era
pollo 16 e lui ne aveva inavvertitamente
assaggiata ed odorato può ripartire da
questa testimonianza molto insolita
rarissima per parlarvi dell'universo in
particolare di come percepiamo
l'universo e di come questa percezione
stia cambiando grazie alle scoperte
della cosmologia moderna dell'astronomia
moderna
ora noi abbiamo cinque sensi a
disposizione ma se ci pensate bene
utilizziamo soltanto la vista per
conoscere l'universo questo un po è
scontato non possiamo certo pensare di
andare a toccare o assaggiare gli
asteroidi e le stelle i pianeti anche
l'odorato e l'udito non ci aiutano certo
molto terra per conoscere universo sono
limitati a piccole distanze
in ogni caso questo piccolo guscio di
atmosfera che già intorno alla terra ci
resta soltanto la vista il fatto di
riuscire a vedere l'universo è meno
scontato di quanto possa sembrare
da una parte è vero che i nostri occhi
gli occhi degli esseri umani sono in un
certo senso fatti per vedere le stelle
sono degli organi che si sono sviluppati
nel corso dell'umanità per accogliere da
analizzare per raccogliere ed analizzare
la luce che ci viene dalla stella che
più vicina a noi il sole però è anche
vero che potremmo vivere per esempio
come nel racconto nightfall di asimo su
un pianeta con molti soli in cui è
sempre giorno gli abitanti non sono di
quel pianeta non sono a conoscenza
dell'esistenza delle stelle
potremmo vivere su un pianeta come
venere coperto sempre da da nubi oppure
sotto la superficie ghiacciata di un
pianeta come delle ipotetiche forme di
vita sul satellite europa di giove
eppure è quindi possiamo considerarci
fortunati in un certo senso di poter
godere ogni notte di questo grande
spettacolo del cielo stellato ed è
proprio grazie all'osservazione di
questo cielo stellato che i nostri
antenati hanno cominciato a conoscere
l'universo osservando a occhio nudo le
stelle e gli allineamenti dei grandi
monumenti dell'antichità ci testimoniano
come questo sia qualcosa che l'umanità
ha fatto da sempre abbiamo utilizzato il
sorgere e tramontare delle costellazioni
come un calendario un grande calendario
astronomico e ci aiutava a gestire
raccolto la semina e abbiamo lentamente
cominciato a distinguere i pianeti dalle
stelle abbiamo capito che la terra un
pianeta che gira intorno al sole
abbiamo capito a descrivere le leggi
abbiamo imparato a descrivere le leggi
che governano il movimento dei pianeti e
particolare abbiamo capito la forza di
gravità che è la forza che che gestisca
che regola praticamente l'universo sulle
grandi scale a partire galileo in poi
abbiamo cominciato a percepire
l'universo profondo grazie ai telescopi
che sono sorte di occhi artificiali dei
nuovi organi di senso gli orchi
artificiale ci permettono di percepire
degli oggetti celesti delle stelle delle
galassie che sarebbero altrimenti
invisibili all'occhio umano
allo stesso tempo ci siamo resi conto
che è che esistono tanti altri colori
nell'universo dei colori che sono
invisibili all'occhio umano
potremmo anzi raccontare la storia
dell'astronomia come un lungo viaggio
alla scoperta dei colori che sono
invisibili all'occhio umano
abbiamo quindi se voi prendete il rosso
e il blu su questo palco questa è luce
la stessa dello stesso tipo di luce una
piccola differenza di energia
dell'ordine del 30 per cento
ma lo spettro della della luce è molto
molto più ampio e quindi con
l'astronomia partire dagli anni trenta
del 1900 abbiamo cominciato a studiare
questi colori invisibili all'occhio
umano abbia cominciato a
a costruire degli strumenti ci
permettevano di osservare
nell'infrarosso alle microonde alle onde
radio e via via abbiamo cominciato a
studiare l'universo anche alle più alte
energie raggi ics ai raggi gamma
abbiamo scoperto un universo
assolutamente incredibile un universo
popolato di cose strane delle ci sono
delle delle stelle come le pulsar che
sono dense e compatte girano intorno a
se stessi in una frazione di secondo
abbiamo scoperto il quasar dei buchi
neri e giganteschi che sputano dei getti
di energia e di materia nello spazio
intergalattico
ma quanti grandi allora l'universo che
cosa c'è là fuori
primo levi un grande scrittore che era
anche uno scienziato peraltro scrisse
nel suo libro se questo è un uomo che la
natura umana è nemica di ogni infinito e
difficile per noi
concepire l'immensità del cosmo e quello
che vorrei fare di provare a fare un
piccolo esperimento per aiutarvi a
visualizzare l'universo come lo possono
visualizzare gli astronomi e vorrei
partire da questa immagine questa è una
fotografia verrà scattata da una sonda
della nasa la sonda osiris pochi mesi fa
quello che vedete al centro di questa
immagine è il nostro pianeta e la terra
quel minuscolo disco che sembra perso in
universi uno spazio completamente vuoto
e il pianeta su cui si è svolta l'intera
storia dell'umanità in basso a destra
vedete la luna
il diametro di questo orbita e l'orbita
della luna e ricerca di un miliardo di
metri miliardo di volte un metro
vediamo che ci asca le più grandi
facciamo un altro salto di un miliardo
di volte andiamo sulla scala di un
miliardo di miliardi di metri
prendete una sfera di questo diametro
arrivati a contenere più di 10 mila
stelle della nostra galassia
sono tutte stelle della nostra galassia
quindi girano insieme al sole intorno
non centro comune del centro della via
lattea intorno a ognuna di queste stelle
e molto probabilmente ci sono dei
pianeti lo sappiamo perché di questi
pianeti ne abbiamo già osservati
tantissimi che conosciamo ormai quasi
quattromila pianeti intorno ad altre
stelle e queste stelle sono talmente
lontane che la luce che ci arriva da
queste stelle impiega decine di anni ad
arrivare a noi ed è in questo senso che
l'astronomia ci offre una sorta di
macchina del tempo ci permette di vedere
l'universo come era nel passato
facciamo un ultimo salto chiama un
miliardo di miliardi di miliardi di
metri ed arriviamo ai confini
dell'universo osservabile con i confini
dell'universo di tutto quello che esiste
probabilmente l'universo è molto più
grande potrebbe essere infinito per
quanto ne sappiamo ma questo è
l'universo osservabile la luce che ci
arriva da queste distanze ha impiegato
l'età dell'universo per arrivare a noi
quindi noi la vediamo come era vediamo
queste regioni dello spazio come erano
poco dopo il big bang essenzialmente e
questo secondo me è una delle immagini
più incredibili che siano mai state
prodotte dalla scienza e dall'umanità è
una fotografia dell'universo nella sua
infanzia prima che si accendessero le
stelle e prima che si formassero i primi
pianeti ci troviamo oggi per la prima
volta nella storia dell'umanità nella
condizione di avere una spiegazione
scientifica convincente precisa
dettagliata dell'origine la struttura è
l'evoluzione dell'universo il progresso
scientifico però ci ha messo di fronte
anche a qualcosa di completamente
inaspettato abbiamo scoperto un universo
oscuro misterioso popolati del popolato
di entità sconosciute che non sappiamo
quasi nulla come la materia oscura che
sembra sostenere le galassie come una
sorta di impalcatura cosmica tutte le
galassie compresa la nostra all energia
oscura che invece sembra spingere
l'espansione dell'universo e farlo
espandere sempre più velocemente
e ci siamo anche dovuti confrontare con
le cosiddette singolarità le singolarità
sono dei punti in cui la fisica nota
essenzialmente impazzisce perde
significato sono sicura rita come i
buchi neri degli oggetti talmente
estremi da distorcere lo spazio e il
tempo intorno a loro che sono fusi
insieme in un'unica entità che si chiama
spazio tempo secondo la teoria della
relatività di einstein e come il big
bang stesso se voi riavvolgete
all'indietro il nastro del tempo
arrivati a un istante in cui
praticamente tutta la materia che esiste
nell'universo è concentrata in un punto
di densità infinita questa è la
frontiera e la cosmologia queste
singolarità sono quelle che molti di noi
forse anche di voi hanno anche hanno
imparato a conoscere grazie ai lavori
del del fisico inglese stephen hawking
che è scomparso da poco che ha scritto
un libro molto conosciuto molto popolare
che si chiama appunto dal big bang ai
buchi neri e questa è la frontiera della
cosmologia moderna in tutti gli istituti
di ricerca nel mio istituto ad amsterdam
tutti gli istituti di ricerca del mondo
stiamo cercando di capire e di conoscere
meglio i misteri e sono racchiusi in
questi in questi nomi che diamo a cose
che ancora non capiamo bene c'è una cosa
però in comune a tutti questi misteri
che sembrano affondare le loro radici
nell'infinitamente piccolo questi
misteri che osserviamo sull'universo ha
grandissima scala sembrano tutti a
fondare le loro radici nella cosiddetta
fisica quantistica la fisica che regola
l'infinitamente piccolo il microcosmo
proviamo allora a vedere a fare il
percorso inverso vi ho visto che cosa
c'è sulle grandissime scala
dell'universo diamo cosa c'è sulle
piccolissime scale e partendo da dal m
la nostra la nostra unità di riferimento
andiamo a vedere che cosa c'è su scale
di un miliardesimo di metro dentro
ciascuno di noi dentro ciascuna cellula
del nostro organismo si guarda te sulla
scala di un miliardesimo di metro
troverete la molecola del dna per
esempio tante molecole in particolare la
molecole del dna che uno spessore
d2 miliardesimi di metro continuiamo a
scendere in dimensioni arriviamo un
miliardesimo di miliardesimo di metro e
arriviamo a risolvere quello che c'è
dentro i nuclei tommy atomici dentro i
protoni e dei nuclei neutroni che stanno
dentro i nuclei atomici la fisica che
governa che regna in questo mondo e la
fisica quantistica di una fisica
stranissima vi faccio un esempio dentro
i protoni protesi sono composti
praticamente da tre particelle
fondamentali che si chiamano works se
prendete la massa di questi tre quarks
vi aspettereste che fosse uguale alla
massa del protone invece la massa del
protone molto più grande della massa dei
cuochi la massa che noi la massa dei
protoni e contenuta non è la massa dei
cuork ma nell'energia che li lega
insieme
secondo l'equazione di hansen è uguale
emmeciquadro energie uguale masper
velocità della luce al quadrato si
manifesta come massa quindi tutto quello
che vedete intorno il vostro stesso peso
deriva da questi minuscoli nodi di
energia che sono contenuti in ciascun
atomo del vostro organismo
ecco la cosmologia moderna ci invita a
cercare la risposta ai grandi problemi
delle grandissime scala dell'universo
in questo mondo nel mondo della fisica
quantistica a cambiare completamente lo
studio di questi di questi fenomeni ea
creare una sorta di ponte tra
infinitamente grande e l'infinitamente
piccolo è nata pochissimo tempo fa una
nuova branca dell'astronomia alcuni voli
avranno sentito parlare
si chiamano le onde gravitazionali e
queste sono importanti perché ci
permette ci offrono delle informazioni
completamente complementari a quelle che
vengono portate dalla luce a qualunque
lunghezza d'onda a sulla terra ci
permettono in particolare di ascoltare
le vibrazioni dello spazio tempo stesso
prodotte da oggetti che altrimenti
resterebbero per sempre nascosti nelle
tenebre del dell'universo profondo come
i buchi neri per esempio ed è proprio
per questo che il premio nobel per la
fisica è stato assegnato per
la scoperta straordinaria nel 2017
e come se esauriti i colori
dell'universo l'umanità stesse
sviluppando dei nuovi organi di senso
per percepire l'universo profonde per
conoscere l'universo è una frontiera
straordinaria della conoscenza che sta
nascendo proprio in questi anni è quello
che stiamo cercando di fare è di
utilizzare queste onde gravitazionali
per stabilire questi collegamenti tra
l'infinitamente grande e l'infinitamente
piccolo lo stiamo cercando di fare con i
buchi neri ne abbiamo già osservati
abbiamo già osservato la fusione di
diversi sistemi di due buchi neri che si
sono fusi in un unico grande buco nero e
questo ci ha permesso
ci sta permettendo di capire tantissimo
sulla l'origine l'evoluzione dei buchi
neri anche sui cosiddetti effetti
quantistici della fisica quantistica che
vengono intorno all orizzonte degli
eventi di questi buchi neri
stiamo cercando la firma della materia
oscura
intorno a questi oggetti intorno a
questi buchi neri e forse analizzando
questa firma riusciremo anche a capire
di che cosa è composta identificare la
natura della materia oscura potremo
capire se l'energia oscura è collegata
veramente all'energia del vuoto nel
vuoto quantistico che differenza dal
voto classico che significa assenza di
materia ribolle continuamente di
attività e forse in maniera ancora più
incredibile stiamo cercando le onde
gravitazionali prodotte dal big bang
stesso e stiamo cercando di verificare
questa teoria assolutamente incredibile
e vertiginosa secondo cui tutto quello
che esiste nell'universo deriva da
piccolissime fluttuazioni quantistiche
che erano presenti nell'universo
primordiale
arriviamo quindi alla fine di questo
viaggio tra infinitamente grande e
l'infinitamente piccolo e vale la pena
chiedersi cosa cosa ne di noi di essere
umani che ruolo giochiamo in questo
grande spettacolo del cosmo
viene quasi da sentirsi piccoli
irrilevanti insignificanti di fronte
all'immensità del cosmo
se ci pensate da copernico in poi siamo
stati spostati prima eravamo la terra
era il centro dell'universo
poi siamo stati spostati siamo diventati
un pianeta che gira intorno al sole uno
dei tanti pianeti che gira intorno al
sole
possiamo scoperto che abbiamo scoperto
che eravamo uno uno dei tanti pianeti
intorno a una delle tante stelle intorno
a una delle tante galassi ma il
messaggio con cui volevo vorrei lasciare
stasera esattamente l'opposto
se come la fisica e l'astronomia moderna
ci stanno dicendo in maniera chiara che
siamo speciali siamo fatti noi esseri
umani di una forma di materia rara
nell'universo
siamo come delle gemme incastonate in
questo mare di oscurità che è l'universo
se ci pensate siamo agglomerati di atomi
che riflettono sulla loro esistenza
sull'esistenza dell'universo una sorta
di autocoscienza e di autoconsapevolezza
dell'universo che si sta generando ecco
vorrei che fosse questo quello che
penserete quando stasera uscirete a
rivedere le stelle grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]